well it's great to be here great to be
back in the Bay Area awesome to be at
Stanford so the first thing I'm gonna
start off with you're gonna you're gonna
hear me talk today a lot about time and
that I'm a big believer in that we can't
waste time and we're together today for
probably 50 minutes or so and there's
going to be a Q&A period as part of this
and many of you I know I've already
researched and research both on myself
and on banjo but most of what you're
gonna hear today is new it's gonna be
new to you and so please as you're
hearing this I just ask you to keep an
open mind I ask you to get your
questions ready because you should have
a lot of questions and whether it's in
the class after this or whether it's in
here I hope that you get an opportunity
to ask them and I'm a very transparent
person so no topic is off topic for me
so please you know bring the heat if you
will so I will start off talking about
everyday we have decisions that we make
that that change the way that our life
will go right and some of them are small
decisions and many of them are large
decisions but we get information today
and in a time in a timeframe that we who
in this room actually is heard of the
term like real-time right real-time
analytics real-time data but real-time
you know for you and I we think of it as
live like right now right we're having a
conversation in real-time the reality is
the way the term has been used in tech
and then our everyday lives real-time is
just the best that people can do and the
problem with real-time is that real time
is truly historical it's already
happened in the sense that when we're
looking at information and data for us
to make decisions that are going to
impact our own lives
real-time data is filtered if you will
at that point it's like the telephone
game I tell you something you tell
someone else by timing it's the third
person it's already been altered you
didn't mean for it to but just we're
humans and that
what happens if something's not
happening live then it can become biased
and if it becomes biased then we're not
making the best decisions that we can
make because we're already looking at
the data the information to make a
decision either late or we're making it
the decision through someone else's eyes
and so today I'm going to talk a lot
about the change in time that we as
human beings are going through right now
and it's the way that you as a human
being are going to be able to make
better decisions in your life it is a
paradigm shift that we're going through
today from this real-time concept to
truly understanding as things happen
live and I'm going to break it down so
we can all look at certain things that
are happening in our own lives today
things that are important so how does
this bring us to to Banjo and what is
what does Banjo do for those of you have
researched Banjo you probably think you
having a pretty good idea but now I'm
going to hopefully blow your minds and
what we really do behind the scenes
years ago I saw that real time was not
good enough real time is the reason why
today unfortunately many people don't
get the aid that they need in the time
they need it to save their life or to
reduce human suffering but if they had
information live or if someone else had
information live it could have made a
decision a better decision that could
have saved someone's life and so at
banjo we are this live intelligence
platform that is built a system that can
truly take in the world of live public
data I know that sounds like a big
statement the world of live public data
but I mean it we process today whether
it's 911 one phone calls lie public
cameras that are out there social media
traffic weather think of all the
different types of live data signals
that are happening around you every
single day happening around us right now
that we don't even realize think how
many of them could impact your life if
you only knew that it was happening or
if you could put five of them together
at once which as we know is doesn't
happen and it's been it's very difficult
so a banjo is able to do
has taken these thousands and thousands
of signals one do I mean by a signal
well if I'm talking to you about 911 one
phone calls and I mean all 911 phone
calls
that's one signal I'm talking to you
about a social network that's only one
signal all of it we process thousands
and thousands of different types of
signals every single second and when we
process that by that mean as we gather
all that information live while it's
still streaming it has not been altered
in real time in this sense of historical
it's still live and in that moment we've
built artificial intelligence that truly
understands what is happening in these
signals but because we have so much data
and so many signals we can also
determine what is real and what is false
because no matter how good a source of
data is no matter where it's coming from
one source of data is I call it as no
data if for those of you that are
entrepreneurs when you get out one day
and you're gonna raise money possibly
from venture capitalists I always tell
those that I'm mentoring in that is one
buyer is no buyer meaning if you only
have one offer it's equivalent to no
offer you know you need to get more same
thing with data you can't make the best
decisions in your life from one piece of
information and so how do you bring in
so many different pieces of information
that are so unrelated to one another but
yet coming together and being combined
from all these multiple sources can tend
to tell us the degree of confidence the
degree of truth that is coming out of
each signal and then to find the anomaly
so now we have all these signals coming
in live from around the world all right
now and then how can we determine what
that means is there something that you
need to act on is there something that's
gonna change your life is something you
know maybe even save your life or a
loved one's life and so how this works
is this data comes in live on a stream
and our system knows what everywhere in
the world looks like now because we've
been listening for a long time and what
you may be thinking to yourself as wow
this this sounds pretty scary someone
that has access to that much data in
fact I think it's the largest live data
store
in the world with more signals than any
other one company has but the big
difference here it's the day I started
this company until now and that's been
it's been a long time
we've always protected user data in a
way that others have never never done
and we've stripped the data of personal
identifiable information in fact most of
our data suppliers we request that they
don't even send us any PII at all but if
they do we patented a process that
scrubs that so that even our engineers
won't have access to PII right so it's
always protecting the user data we as a
company have never sold data ever and
you may think like we'll wait a minute
you have this much data and this much
insights and you guys know what's going
on before anybody else why wouldn't you
have sold the data we'll talk later
about ethics and artificial intelligence
and the way that we've led this company
since the day we started it and why
we've made those decisions but getting
back now to how all of this information
comes in and we know what normal looks
like so when normal is disrupted and
then we can validate that disruption by
multiple other types of signals that
cannot be influenced by another signal
we can verify that something's happening
let me give you a few instances last
year October 1st in the city of Las
Vegas you guys all know about the large
shooting that took place our system was
listening and in the moment of that
shooting our system knew that not only
was there shooting that it was affecting
many people at the route 91 harvest fest
on the strip in Las Vegas and it knew
where the shooter was and it knew all of
this before the 9/11 one phone call even
was made before the 9-1-1 call was even
made this system had gone through all of
this information had made sense of it
and had validated it and verified it and
we as a company sent that information
out to the media rate to let them know
that this was happening unfortunately
the reality of it is the media
they get it they'll do their
fact-checking but they also got to think
about how they're gonna put headlines on
things or when they're gonna send
something out so there's a delay this is
when we go to back to real time we were
at live in the difference between live
information not getting out in the Vegas
incident police officer showed up to the
wrong hotels many of the people hundreds
of people that needed to go to the
hospital and finally made it to the
hospital the hospitals didn't know that
there was a large shooting that happened
until people started showing up at the
doorstep almost an hour later then
doctors had to be paged and that takes
another hour before doctors come in and
blood has to be transferred transferred
to the hospital that golden opportunity
to save that life is now long gone we
don't think as a society that this is
even possible because we see in movies
like that's not how it works in the
movies well it's not real life this is
real life parkland school shooting the
same way the hospitals were completely
unprepared because they don't have live
information being fed to them we would
think they would but they do not and so
that has to change
and so I banjo we're making sure that
all of this information that's being
collected is being collected for the
purposes of one mission and this is a
part in Silicon Valley and not just in
Silicon Valley but outside where our
mission really changes and
differentiates us from the rest in the
sense that it's not a mission statement
it's a mission and the mission is to
save human life and to reduce human
suffering by using artificial
intelligence for good and you can say
well what is good I just stopped it at
that statement right there that's what
good is because we can all sit here and
justify how to use artificial
intelligence against data in a way we
believe is good but if you really stop
and think about it and you ask yourself
the question how do you feel about that
and for just one moment you get that
little tingly sensation in your gut it's
probably not the right thing to do for
example we could be selling this data
today
and completely disrupting the stock
market there's no doubt that we know
things long before the high-frequency
traders know them in Wall Street and
we've been offered contracts of dollar
amounts that would blow your mind and
we've always said no people thought I
was crazy way back when when we were
filing patents on how to protect user
privacy because no one cared eight years
ago about that right now today it's a
big topic it's everyone's like there's a
spotlight on it but we never wavered
from that and that's what's put us in
the position today where people trust us
by bringing in this anonymize data but
remember it truly is anonymized and it's
public data it's just being brought in
at a speed a speed of live that others
have never been able to do and verifying
it so that you or I can make a big
difference in the world and so let me
give you a few examples of how of how
this technology is being harnessed about
Oh three months ago now an attorney
general from a different state contacted
me and said I've seen the demo of your
of what your product can do and it's
amazing how you on silo all of these
data sources from all these different
places to get us information faster for
the purposes of saving our citizens
lives in our state well we would like to
see if you could put a dent and
child-abduction and I said okay I
personally understand and have a you can
relate to child abduction so how can we
solve it and so he what he did is he
invited us down for a statewide a drill
where they actually abducted a real
child with an actor and hundreds of
police officers different agencies
participated in this just like if the
child had been abducted and the federal
agencies were there and the state
agencies is there and the local agencies
and when this child was abducted they
went ours many many hours in fact I
think the report came out that it was
like 13 hours later they just happened
upon the child by getting a good lead a
good tip that led them to the child but
the average statistic is that the
average child taken by a stranger
would have unfortunately died within the
first three hours after the abduction
and so when the drill was done the
Attorney General and his investigators
looked at our information that had gone
out to them live we didn't know anything
about the drill we didn't know any of
the details and what they determined is
that they had been using us at that time
that that child would have been
recovered in just a few minutes after
the abduction and almost most certainly
would have obviously been alive which is
the difference between life and death of
a child it was so profound to them that
this attorney general went to many other
states Attorney General's all the way to
the federal government and all the way
down to local police departments not in
his state but across the United States
and in just a few short months this
software this technology now being used
for child abduction who has now forever
changed the way children will be
recovered in this country and I assure
you as I'm standing here today that
years from now we look back on the
successful rate of recovery when a child
is abducted it will have been changed
forever because of something that
happened literally 90 days ago and so
now we move from an amazing opportunity
to save the life of a child to other
opportunities that this thing that this
technology allows us to harness for
example we all hear about the opioid
crisis that's ravaging throughout this
country and we you know we hear that
we're putting a lot of money into it
meaning the the government's put nine
billion dollars recently into it but is
it really making a difference and the
problem that we find is that there's all
these silos of data we think in a
perfect world that everybody works
together it couldn't be further from the
truth
federal government doesn't work with
state government state government
doesn't work with local governments they
don't work with private companies a lot
of reasons for that
protectionism
old I'll call it tribal wars between
agencies or between private companies
private companies not wanting government
to have access to information but all
the data to solve the opioid crisis is
literally right in front of us it's just
never been put together in a way that
gives us a clear picture live in order
to get ahead of the problem we're always
on our heels with the problem we're
never able to get in front and now with
banjo and what we've developed with all
this live information the ability now to
get in front of the opioid crisis is now
in front of us and we were literally
will be able to put a massive dent in
that a real dent a measurable day and
you know a lot of you are sitting here
today saying well why haven't I seen
this and why when I've researched banjo
why haven't I seen or heard any of this
well it's on purpose well we're very
transparent and I said to you before
today when I got up here please ask me
any question that comes to mind because
I'm we are very transparent I'm very
transparent sometimes too transparent
but I want you guys to be able to
understand how this is used why it's
used so you truly get an understanding
because what's hard is when you're very
quiet like we are and I'm gonna tell you
why we're quiet in a minute but it's
hard to educate on a technology that
sounds like well it sounds like mythical
sounds like this is not possible and
this is possible why didn't a Google do
it why didn't a Microsoft do it how
could this have not have already existed
and there's a couple of simple reasons
for that and number one is you know
having someone internally that has
vision and a mission to get something
accomplished that's very personal to
them number two is having the
credibility to get access to a
tremendous amount of data sources that
as I said with all these silos
government when trust some private
companies with data and vice versa and
we've broken those walls down but it's
hard when you don't go out there and you
don't put yourself out there publicly
but the reason we just
a long time ago if the last major
article on us that I did was about four
years ago and it was very distracting at
the time because everybody who realized
what we had the acquisition offers from
the Giants came and they kept getting
bigger and bigger and bigger to where
our investors even our employees were
like this is game-changing you know we
should we should you know think about
selling or maybe it was you should think
about selling this technology or using
this technology in the stock market but
remember what I told you we only use
this for saving human life and reducing
human suffering period the end and so if
it doesn't meet that goal its I can't be
tempted by money we can't be tempted by
money and that's a hard thing for people
to say right and it even sounds a little
like BS with you sitting out there like
and and so when I was introduced they
said I have a little bit of unusual
background well we all do we all have
different life experiences right life
experiences that are going to enable you
to create something amazing whether you
become an entrepreneur and start it
yourself or where you support other
entrepreneurs to create amazing change
and it's not unlike what has happened
here at Banjo and why this exists today
so for me I'm a homeless kid and I and I
when I say homeless I mean like I was
really homeless for years I lived under
the underpass of a freeway I ate out of
the dumpsters I never went to high
school you know and people say well why
would you be homeless and when and how
long and and well there's a lot of
circumstances and it starts up in the
home and things happen in the home that
you have to escape from and and I
rebelled and escaped from that before I
could even get a driver's license and so
no education no driver's license no
money and there I am on the streets of
LA for a long time and for years and so
I understand what it's like to live with
with literally nothing not even your
dignity and then I was fortunate enough
that
there was an opportunity for me to go
into the military during Desert Storm
for many of you weren't even born then
but in 1990 when Desert Storm was
starting up they needed able bodies and
I was able body they didn't have an
education but I was an able body person
and so I was able to get myself out of
the streets and bring myself into the
military where I excelled and that
really helped me start a new foundation
for myself gave me sir pride gave me
some dignity and and then eventually
gave me the wherewithal and the finances
to get an education and from that
education I spent time as you guys heard
in becoming a chief mechanic and a top
NASCAR team because I want to understand
what that was about I then went and
studied from everything from the FBI to
law enforcement to homicide
investigation because I wanted to become
a crime-scene investigator before there
was the TV show crime scene
investigation because I wanted to
understand what it was like to solve
hard challenges and and so I went out
there in law enforcement and I did that
for a while and then I was lucky enough
to start hacking my way through things
and eventually found myself at a few of
these big hackathons the last major one
was at Google and when I won that you
know the investors here in Silicon
Valley asked me who I was because I
wasn't from here and I was able to raise
a significant amount of money and here
we are and you know years later with
banjo you know being so transformational
it didn't start off transformational
right because the technology and
artificial intelligence didn't even
exist when we started it but you know we
quickly adopted it on I think it was
like 2012-2013 we were doing artificial
intelligence at a level of still that I
believe it most still aren't even doing
but we always thought about the ethical
the ethical constraints and then our
ethics around artificial intelligence
and so as you as entrepreneurs as you
get out there to start in your journey I
want you to think about how are you
going to ask yourself
what is the ethical use of artificial
intelligence how should we be using this
what is the best thing that we can do
not just for yourself but for mankind
and it's a hard decision I sit there and
listen to my friends who run big
companies today and they sit there and
justify how they're selling people's
data and making money for something like
advertising and I say and I quickly say
to them I said well those people don't
know you're selling their data they say
no but we justify it because you know
they've opted in to to use this so
therefore we're selling that and I'm not
here to pass judgment on them and I'm
not passing judgment but for me I don't
like the way that feels
and so I even if I could sit there and
justify to myself I know what that
initial feeling is and so what I ask you
to do because this is a very hard
subject that humanity has to deal with
today not just the artificial
intelligence in the ethics around it the
ethics around people's data is how does
it make you feel and I don't mean how
does it make you feel that that you've
sat there and convinced yourself how it
makes you feel go with that initial
instinct in your gut and you know what
I'm talking about you feel that way
before an exam you feel that way before
you maybe there's a tough question or a
tough conversation you got to have with
somebody we inherently know what the
right thing to do is we just ignore it
we ignore it because it's either
uncomfortable or there's an advantage to
us maybe financially to ignore and that
gets me to the other point people always
tell me Damian this is great what Banjo
doing in saving lives at this level is
unprecedented
but most people would use your
technology and they go make money first
go make a lot of money and then you
become altruistic you don't become
altruistic now because you can never
become a big company and I'm not just
sitting here to prove them wrong
but we are going to prove them wrong
because this is already becoming a big
company and we have been altruistic
about it our mission is very altruistic
and you can be altruistic in the things
that you want to do in life and don't
let people tell you that altruism at the
end of the day comes at the cost of
financial gain right and we can have a
whole debate and discussion about
what does it mean to be a financial gain
and how do you how should you feel about
that or or what makes you feel
successful is that just it's just money
right now don't get me wrong this has to
make money this has to be successful in
a significant way or else we could never
continue to grow and we would never
achieve our mission of the amount of
lives and ending of human suffering that
we want to do but each and every single
person in this room you have a unique
life story like I have a unique life
story yours is different different is
not better or worse it's that it's
different you can create and do amazing
things things that I could never even
dream of things that I couldn't even
understand because if your unique
experiences because the things in life
that you're either dealing with today
you dealt with before or the things that
you aspire that you want to accomplish
in the future and that's why you can
create something amazing even if you're
sitting there today and say and I don't
know that's for me that's okay you don't
have to make a decision today
how much best for you today but I can
assure you if some homeless kid with no
education who's probably my best
accomplishment in life is the fact that
I'm not in prison has been able to
achieve something of this magnitude that
is literally changing the way that we
will be able to deliver information to
people faster you will get information
faster that it'll make it'll make a
massive change in your life for the
better or for your loved ones lives for
the better you can do anything and so
don't feel the pressures of you needing
to go out and start something I mean
every time I come and speak at one of
these things everyone feels this need
that they need to become the
entrepreneur and come out with the next
big thing not so I'm grateful that
behind me I have an amazing team of
people and have had an amazing team of
people for almost eight years ago when I
started this several when we're sitting
here that were there the day I started
it and are still with me today and I'm
grateful that they didn't go out on
their their entre
ventures of their own that they've been
able to support the craziness coming out
of my head every day to make it a
reality and so just because you don't
have that desire maybe to go out and do
something of your own
that doesn't mean you don't play a
significant role in making it happen the
idea might have been mine to change the
world from real time to life or to how
we can save human lives or how we can
rescue children going forward that have
been abducted but without the amazing
team behind me the people that also
believed in giving up things in their
life giving up opportunities that other
tech companies came to them and said hey
come work on this next advertising
you'll make more money right now in the
short term but all these folks decided
for the long-term game the long-term
gain of that of saving human life was
was their mission and I'm grateful to
them every day and it just has the
people that you'll work with to create
something amazing we'll be grateful and
not only grateful it wouldn't have
happened without you
so just know that going forward that you
don't have to lead the change to create
the change and I can't overemphasize
that enough and especially in such a
community as we're in today in Silicon
Valley and here at Stanford I know all
of you are destined to do great things
either from starting something or being
the sparks inside something that'll make
that'll make big difference in humanity
and all that I ask is that you ask
yourself that internal question when
you're doing it is what are the ethics
around this how should we treat
technology artificial intelligence how
should we treat data and ask yourself
the question if you weren't in this and
you really have to divorce yourself from
the moment and this was being done to
you without you knowing about it how
would you be okay with it
and if you get that little tinge like I
said that's your real answer you may
choose to ignore it
but you can't say that you never felt it